si on regarde les chiffres en termes de
dégâts économiques en termes de dégâts
sanitaires nous sommes du sud
nous sommes avec l'italie et l'espagne
et de notre efficacité collective qui
allie un mystérieux avec la force
économique et nous met incontestablement
du côté des pays du sud et je pense que
pour les français ça une importance tout
à fait particulière de par la conviction
profonde et justifier qu'ils ont eu
pendant très longtemps de bénéficier
d'un état très performant il était
pénible il était autoritaire il était
bureaucratique mais il marchait et il
nous ranger dans la catégorie des
puissances qui compte et qui ont pour
elles cette efficacité collective
au delà de l'économie et on s'aperçoit
que même celles là nous ne l'avons plus
donc je crois que c'est nous tombons de
haut
nous français dans cette crise et le
réveil va être très dur
[Musique]